on va passer au témoins du jour on va
revenir sur l'affaire Palmade parce
qu'on est des rebondissements près de 8
mois après le grave accident causé par
voilà cette affaire deux éléments
importants viennent d'être publiés
l'expertise médicale et l'expertise
d'accidentologie on va parler dans un
instant avec Myriam Palomba qui vont
être détailler ses rapports et vous
entendrez également Morad bâti l'avocat
de la famille qui viendra réagir à tout
ça apparemment c'est c'est des bonnes
nouvelles enfin des bonnes nouvelles
c'est c'est entre guillemets pour Pierre
Palmas gérer exactement
désormais considéré comme seul
responsable par un expert en
accidentologie Pierre Palmade a provoqué
il y a plus de 7 mois un grave accident
de la route sous l'emprise de stupéfiant
un acte responsable en fait de prendre
la drogue aller sur la route parmi les
victimes ce jour-là une femme enceinte
qui a perdu son bébé mais alors que le
comédien avait été mis en examen pour
homicide involontaire cette affaire
complexe vient de connaître un
rebondissement cet enfant est né viable
mais il est mort in utero alors cette
expertise est-elle définitive que
change-t-elle concrètement comment
l'affaire va-t-elle évoluer et que
risque-t-il désormais à faire Palma de
l'humoriste pourrait ne pas être jugé
pour homicide involontaire comprenez
vous la colère après cette décision
[Musique]
merci à Mourad batik d'être avec nous et
merci à Myriam Palomba d'être avec nous
également alors merci Myriam est-ce
qu'on peut faire un point sur l'affaire
Palmade parce que ça rebondit alors
appeler
pas des problèmes de micro mais Myriam
merci les Chéries voilà c'est bon tente
rien ne t'inquiète pas tout est géré
tout est réglé alors comme vous souvenez
cette affaire à beaucoup
je parle plus fort d'accord alors cette
affaire a ému énormément les Français
c'était donc le 10 février dernier sur
une route départementale de
Seine-et-Marne la voiture que Pierre
Palmade conduisait une 3000 vues percute
violemment une autre voiture et là
malheureusement fait trois blessés
graves donc un papa à l'époque le
conducteur qui avait 37 ans son fils de
6 ans et une jeune une jeune future
maman qui était enceinte de 6 mois à la
suite de cet Pierre Palmade a été mis en
examen pour homicide et blessures
involontaires il a été mis en sous
contrôle judiciaire il a fait des
allers-retours à l'hôpital
à l'hôpital régulièrement notamment
parce qu'il a fait un AVC et depuis juin
il est assigné à résidence à Bordeaux
sous contrôle judiciaire à contrôle
judiciaire qu'il oblige évidemment à ne
plus conduire à suivre des soins
psychologiques et pour soigner son
addictologie à la drogue et également de
ne pas rentrer en contact avec la
famille des blessés ce qui est nouveau
aujourd'hui c'est que une expertise a
été rendue au juge d'instruction le 8
août dernier une expertise qui a été
fait par faite par trois
experts agréés par la Cour de cassation
et cette expertise pourrait remettre en
cause les les charges pour pesticides à
volontaire qui qui ont été décrétées
contre Pierre Palmade alors ce qu'il
faut savoir donc ce que vous dites là la
première info donc tomber hier est un
tournant dans l'affaire puisque
l'expertise médicale qui a été remise à
la justice et claire elle conclut que
l'enfant portait par la dame présente
dans la voiture n'était pas vivant à sa
naissance ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
qu'un fœtus ne dispose pas de
personnalité juridique en gros s'il fait
tu sais mort avant accouchement on ne
peut pas parler d'homicide si le bébé a
respiré ne serait-ce que quelques
secondes après l'accouchement là on peut
parler d'homicide dans le cas de Pierre
Palmade donc c'était homicide
involontaire donc le 8 août dernier
l'expertise médicale a été transmise à
la justice elle a été menée par trois
experts comme l'a dit Myriam un médecin
légiste un pédiatre des hôpitaux et un
médecin
donc ils ont rendu cette expertise et
effectivement le bébé n'ayant présenté
aucun signe de vie à la naissance il
faut savoir qu'un foetus il est
considéré comme faisant partie du corps
de la mer donc c'est pas un être humain
et donc pour Palmade c'est une victoire
une première victoire énorme judiciaire
parce que ça veut dire que il ne risque
plus dix ans de prison pour homicide
involontaire blessure involontaire et
risquera 5 ou 7 ans de prison en
fonction des d'un jugement éventuel et
moi ce que je voulais demander à mettre
mouradmatique justement c'est que cette
expertise était réalisée par des ponts
vous vous êtes l'avocat des victimes
est-ce que c'est définitif ou est-ce que
vous pouvez contester cette expertise
alors on peut demander une
contre-expertise mais la
contre-expertise il y a de très fortes
chances qu'elle conduisent au même
conclusions donc en réalité le problème
il vient pas des experts il vient pas de
l'expertise le problème il vient en
réalité du législateur c'est à dire que
ceux qui ont fait la loi en France
estiment qu'un être vivant n'acquiert la
personnalité juridique qu'à partir du
moment où comme la dis Cyril il y a une
première respiration et ça pose un vrai
problème et c'est aussi la raison pour
laquelle je viens sur ce plateau ce soir
c'est parce que il faut que le
législateur change la loi parce que
on le sait tous quand une personne meurt
dans l'inconscient collectif quand une
personne meurt c'est que son cœur
s'arrête de battre et donc on associe la
mort à l'arrêt cardiaque et en revanche
ce que va faire le législateur par une
fiction juridique c'est qu'il va
associer la naissance non pas au cœur
qui bat mais à une première respiration
autrement dit se foetus qui avait plus
de 24 semaines qui étaient viable parce
que c'est ça ce que nous dit cette
expertise en fait pour qu'un enfant
acquiert la personnalité juridique il
faut qu'il soit né viable et vivant
viable on dit il n'y a pas de difficulté
il avait plus de 24 semaines il pèsait
plus de 500 g en l'espèce il pesait un
kilo et puis c'est un enfant qui a les
naître les parents avaient prévu de lui
donner un prénom sa chambre était prête
il avait des jouets des doudous tout
était prêt donc il était viable et on
dit il est viable d'accord dont acte
mais il n'est pas vivant
or ce que l'expertise nous dit c'est
qu'il n'est pas vivant
directement lié à l'accident mais
effectivement on est dans une situation
tout à fait ubuesque et absurde ou une
personne en l'espèce monsieur Palma ne
peut pas être poursuivi pour homicide
involontaire parce que le fœtus
n'acquiert pas n'a pas acquis la
personnalité juridique pourquoi on en
parle c'est parce que c'est extrêmement
important dans la faire les premières
analyses avaient pourtant affirmé que le
fœtus serait né je cite viable et vivant
à 22h18 le soir de l'accident par une
césarienne c'est c'était les premières
années la mort n'aurait été déclarée
qu'à 22h51 donc 33 minutes plus tard
dans un contexte d'accident de la voie
publique toujours selon cet examen
l'enfant ne présentait visiblement
aucune malformation finalement donc les
trois spécialistes affirment que le bébé
n'a pas présenté de signes de vie
extra-utérine la mort fœtal serait
survenue avant l'accouchement de 22h18
voilà tous les arguments indiquent que
la victime est a été victime d'une mort
fœtal in utero dont la survenue peut
être adapté entre 21h50 et 22h10 que je
mais la mort elle était causée par
l'accident c'est ça que je comprends
bien la mort elle a été causée par
l'accident la question c'est est-ce
qu'il était vivant est-ce que le fait de
suite c'est complètement mais sur la
tête c'est complètement absurde et ça
n'aurait pas eu d'accident le bébé c'est
là exactement
il faut que le législateur change la loi
et il faut que le on peut on peut
regarder on va prendre un exemple en
fait que ils avaient même que le bébé
était déjà mort une fois sorti du ventre
de sa maman ils ont eu l'accident le
bébé était vivant il est mort par le
choc accident mais il fallait qu'il soit
encore vivant une fois qu'il est sorti
mais pour que pour que ce soit on
considère que c'est un homicide
involontaire exactement c'est une
absurdité c'est une absurdité juridique
c'est fou alors c'est c'est oui cette
jurisprudence vous me dites je me trompe
mais il me semble qu'elle avait été
décidée par rapport notamment aux droits
à l'avortement c'est pour ça que cette
qu'on estime qu'un fœtus je dis pas que
je suis d'accord avec faire ça mais en
tout cas qu'un fœtus mort dans le ventre
de sa mère ne peut pas être
considérément il a des limites parce que
la réalité c'est que le législateur il a
encadré le droit à l'intervention
volontaire de grossesse et au-delà de 14
semaines on ne peut plus intervenir sur
le fœtus ça veut donc dire que
postérieurement à 14 semaines vous voyez
en fait à partir en toute 14 semaines on
dit ok pas de difficulté on peut avorter
à partir de 14 semaines jusqu'à la
naissance on est dans un espèce de flou
artistique à la naissance il acquiert la
personne a été juridique et entre les
deux on ne peut pas avorter mais il
n'acquerre pas la personnalité juridique
donc en fait on est dans un espèce de no
man's land c'est un no man's land qui
est extrêmement préjudiciable et je
pense que toutes les mères qui ont porté
un enfant et qui sont à 24 semaines 25
semaines 28 semaines où elle porte leur
enfant ça veut dire quelque chose c'est
pas juste un être qui fait partie d'elle
c'est c'est un être vivant qui mérite la
personnalité juridique Gilles juste
pour faire Palmade
effectivement pour des raisons encore
inconnues il aurait dévié sur la gauche
et percuté de plein fouet la voiture des
trois victimes et qu'il en serait
totalement responsable effectivement
donc la cause fondamentale de l'accident
ressort ainsi exclusivement lié à une
faute de conduite caractérisée et ça a
un déport intégral dans la voie de sens
opposé une absence de reprise de
trajectoire en correction c'est le
rapport d'extrait d'expertise
d'accidentologie il s'agit visiblement
pas de la vitesse puisque l'humoriste
roulait à 87 km/h au lieu de 80 bon
c'est un petit excès de vitesse mais
voilà c'est pas il était pas à 200 ni à
l'état du véhicule qui était visiblement
récent en parfait état et révisé comme
il se doit c'est uniquement le
changement de trajectoire brutal qui a
causé l'accident l'expert estime que le
déport effectué par Pierre pas mal sur
la route serait lié à je cite la
correction disproportionnée d'un premier
écart à droite il a été déporté alors on
ne sait pas si c'est une faute
d'inattention pour quelle raison vers la
droite il a voulu corriger et partir à
gauche et à percuter la voiture et Cyril
vous l'avez dit contrôle technique ok
véhicule en parfait état donc là pour le
coup ça veut dire que il ne pourra plus
c'est ça ça défense ne pourra plus dire
que le véhicule était par exemple en
mauvais état on a également parlé d'un
SMS qui aurait déconcentré Pierre
Palmade et qui aurait pu être à
l'origine de l'accident mais apparemment
l'expert ne trouve pas de rapport direct
avec sa sortie de route non pour lui
c'est juste un conducteur qui fait une
erreur de conduite ça c'est les
conclusions de l'expertise
que Pierre Palmade était sous l'emprise
de stupéfice et que et que les drogues
consommées auraient pu conduire à cette
ils disent des effets psychotropes
délétères sur la conduite surestimation
de ses capacités illusion d'une absence
de fatigue ou sensibilité accrue à la
lumière des phares pour la cocaïne selon
l'expert en accidentologie la ferme je
cite que la faute de Pierre Palmade est
d'autant plus totale qui n'a cherché à
aucun moment à freiner après son
changement de trajectoire brutal il n'y
a corriger cet écart avant la collision
il y a un élément pour sa défense
de palmat un élément qui est tombé
qui pourrait peut-être important c'est
l'enfant qui était assis à l'arrière du
véhicule percuté par Pierre Palmade
n'était pas sur un rehausseur et c'est
ce qu'on a d'ailleurs ça c'est foot de
parler de ça voilà on rappelle que c'est
obligatoire pour les enfants et ça
l'était donc pour le petit 6 ans qui
était grièvement blessé dans l'accident
et qui bien sûr on pense fort ce soir
mais ça ça a été un élément absolument
et tous ces éléments paraissent
inhumains déplacés mais c'est
effectivement très important pour la
qualification juridique et peut-être
potentiellement pour la peine à laquelle
sera condamné Pierre Palmade Cyril c'est
pour ça que toutes ces expertises
s'ajoutent il y en a une qui est
extrêmement favorable à Pierre Palmade
et le fait qu'il soit responsable comme
conducteur potentiellement il est
présumé innocent mais le fait qu'il soit
potentiellement responsable ça c'est une
charge accrue pour lui alors moi de bâti
est-ce que c'est c'est deux nouvelles
infos dans l'affaire vous qui êtes
avocat des victimes pour vous c'est
c'est pas des c'est pas des bonnes
nouvelles alors c'est pas forcément des
bonnes nouvelles mais ça nous laisse le
champ des possibles je pense il faut
qu'aujourd'hui le législateur et les
députés les sénateurs qui vous écoutent
qui vous regardent changent la loi il
faut que la notion de vivant soit liée à
la notion de battement cardiaque et plus
à la notion de respiration je rappelle
pour votre information dans ce dans ce
dossier le cœur de l'enfant a battu
évidemment in utero et abattu une fois
que il y a eu une césarienne c'est à
dire que si on avait considéré qu'un
être vivant l'est à partir du moment où
le cœur bat et ben l'enfant aurait été
considéré vivant on a considéré par
cette fiction juridique qu'il fallait
qu'il y ait une respiration il n'y a pas
eu de respiration et donc pas de
personnalité juridique pour pour la
réaction de la maman
à côté vous écoutez elle a pris ça bah
écoutez c'est une réaction de maman tout
à fait normale je pense que toutes les
mamans qui vous regardent ce soir
peuvent comprendre elle est dévastée
elle ne comprend pas cette fiction
juridique qui nie la personnalité de son
enfant qui qui était prêt à naître qui
était viable qui était en bonne santé
qui était en tout point dans les courbes
de taille de croissance de poids pile là
où il fallait donc évidemment et
nécessairement c'est quelque chose
duquel elle aura beaucoup beaucoup de
mal à se remettre dans quel état et
toute la famille à huit mois après
l'accident chacun évolue différemment
vous savez que le conducteur lui sort à
peine de l'hôpital après après de très
nombreux mois et encore plus
d'opérations donc voilà lui il est très
heurté physiquement et on a du côté du
côté de de la maman des séquelles
psychologiques très importants très
profond desquels elle aura du mal à se
remettre alors on a vu qu'il y avait un
élément qui était tombé aussi c'est que
l'enfant qui était assis à l'arrière du
véhicule n'était pas sur un réhausseur
pour vous c'est c'est c'est c'est
pas une bonne nouvelle non plus pour moi
c'est un événement on est du côté des
victimes on n'a pas à se justifier c'est
pas nous qui sommes sur le banc de
l'accusation donc on va pas commencer à
se justifier sur sur des éléments pour
lesquels on est parfaitement victimes et
un choc
non ça jouera pas puisque ça ce sont des
questions assurantielles mais qui
n'interfèrent pas dans la culpabilité ou
dans l'information judiciaire qui a été
ouverte alors husky donc il coûte le
conducteur du véhicule percuté par
Pierre Palmade il est resté très
nombreux mois à l'hôpital et encore de
gros problèmes de santé on lui a demandé
de ses nouvelles ça ne va pas très fort
pour lui huit mois après l'accident il
n'a toujours pas repris une vie normale
écouter
maintenant
peut-être c'est bientôt opération aussi
pour notre temps de mon rendez-vous
c'est la Semaine
bientôt je suis allé
c'est trop fatigué voilà donc il est il
est encore extrêmement touché c'est
quelqu'un qui c'est quelqu'un qui qui se
levait le matin qui travaillait qui
bossait qui allait chercher son salaire
qui avait une vie rangée normale et qui
depuis 6 8 moi et alité en train de
subir des opérations tous les quatre
matins donc nécessairement aussi bien
physiquement que psychologiquement il
nous dit il est il affecté il nous dit
qu'il n'ose même plus parler poser la
question à sa belle-sœur qui a perdu son
bébé hein
l'état de santé de la famille
psychologique et physique et très
compliqué et est-ce que mettre l'enfant
a pu reprendre une scolarité normale
est-ce qu'il est encore suivi est-ce
qu'il a des séquelles il a un corset par
exemple il est toujours suivi médicament
enfin au niveau au niveau médical et au
niveau psychologique mais il reprend il
reprend les chemins de l'école et le
chemin de la scolarité très bien oui
est-ce que vous moi j'ai une question
qui qui peut choquer mais est-ce que
vous pensez vu les les expertises là
est-ce qu'il y aura vraiment un procès
pierre Palma d'un jour ah oui vous
pensez il y aura un procès évidemment il
y aura un procès et une information
judiciaire qui est en cours il y a un
magistrat instructeur une juge
d'instruction à l'espèce qui a été
désignée sur le dossier qui procède à
son enquête l'enquête l'instruction
avance évidemment je peux pas vous en
parce que moi même je suis soumis au
secret de l'instruction mais le dossier
le dossier avance Myriam il y a la
question on a l'impression que les
derniers éléments qui tombent sont
plutôt favorables à Pierre Palmade oui
les derniers événements sont plutôt fait
favorables à Pierre Palmade après bon
voilà il y a toute la dimension morale
on est enfin j'imagine je me mets dans
la tête de des spectateurs ça peut
paraître extrêmement injuste que tout
que cette expertise en tout cas des
sites que il ne sera pas inculper pour
homicide
à volontaire exactement donc c'est vrai
que c'est complètement ubuesque ce que
vous nous racontez
que ça puisse être voilà mis en place
dans les cas d'avortement mais après la
justice doit s'adapter je pense à chaque
à chaque cas et là c'est vrai que c'est
un cas qui est complètement différent
aujourd'hui le truc qu'il faut la seule
question qu'il faut se poser c'est
est-ce que le bébé serait vivant
aujourd'hui sans l'accident
et vous avez la réponse
il y a la réponse puisqu'ils disent que
le bébé était viable et que
effectivement l'accident est à l'origine
des différents traumatis qui a subi la
maman et qui ont conduit à
l'accouchement précocement de l'enfant
de très près merci en tout cas moi merci
Myriam d'avoir été avec nous tout de
suite au sein de la